Hi everybody.
Welcome to toxic Google.
My name is Nadia and I'm very excited to introduce Demitri Martin.
So random falls the documented into the room.
[inaudible]
thanks everybody.
Thank you so much for coming today.
I appreciate it.
I'm very excited.
Everyone here is very excited.
Um,
so we're going to do some questions and then,
uh,
at the end I'll let you guys know when and we'll open it up to Q and.
A.
We can pass the mic around.
So start thinking if anyone has anything.
Um,
so the movie dean,
uh,
I watched it really,
really great,
really loved it.
Um,
and if I miss anything let me know.
But you directed,
you wrote it,
you produced it and you did all the sketches and you start in it?
Yes.
Okay.
Wow.
A lot of Hubris.
Yeah.
And it all out there though.
Can you talk us through,
like when you had the idea and just writing,
getting all the way to filming?
I mostly do standup comedy and I got into stand up to do stand up.
I like writing jokes and I like telling him,
I feel lucky that I can do it as a job.
I found a way to make money doing it.
But along the way,
um,
mostly in my notebooks,
just from writing jokes by hand,
which I still like to do,
you know,
type them into my phone sometimes.
But usually I carry a little notebook and just write down ideas along the way.
Doing that every day,
other ideas started to come out.
Sometimes there were drawings,
just a little line drawings and sometimes,
I don't know,
like a idea for a book or a short story and movie ideas.
We're in there.
Most of them were like higher concept.
For whatever reason.
I was drawn to the idea of making movies about outer space or I dunno,
underwater or whatever the hell I thought I was going to do.
But then I did sell a couple of pitches over the years and I got money,
the scripts,
which was cool.
Excuse me,
I had this free club soda that you guys gave me.
Thank you.
But I chose poorly because I'm in a burp through my conversation.
But I love this.
There's mixed berry thing here.
I'm not sponsored by them or anything.
Yeah.
So,
um,
after I sold those pitches,
I thought,
hey,
I'm going to get to make these,
these,
these concept.
He movies,
they'll get made in Hollywood and maybe I'll get to play a part in them,
but they never got made.
So it was nice to get money,
but it never went anywhere.
So after some years I decided if I'm going to have a shot at making movies,
I'll have to write them myself for myself and I'll direct them and I'll learn
how to do each of these roles so that I can have creative control and also get
the thing made.
I can make it happen.
And then after that I realized,
well,
I'll have to write a small idea cause I had no one's going to give me money to
do a big movie.
So I wrote this one,
which is a very personal,
smaller story,
I guess you say.
Um,
I was lucky I got Kevin Kline to play my dad in the movie.
And that made it a real movie that helped me get the financing.
A lot of it came together when Kevin responded to the script and said he would
do it.
So,
um,
that was like a big leap in the process.
Like that kind of got me down the road to actually making the movie.
It took a while though.
It's,
it's weird when you make a small indie film like this one,
nobody cares.
Nobody wants a movie.
No,
he's waiting for it.
So you have to hustle and try to find your way through it.
Um,
but I did and I'm grateful now because I have a finished movie and it's actually
going to be a movie theaters,
which was,
there was no guarantee that would happen.
So I'm trying to focus on that and not worry about how well it will do or,
um,
just how nasty people will be online.
I mean,
I don't think that there's anything that's would provoked that,
but of course,
you know,
I think it's,
it's,
it's a colder world these days.
So,
uh,
making something heartfelt has a certain scariness to it,
you know,
they vulnerable.
Yeah,
I think it is.
It's certainly more vulnerable than I've been in my standup.
I like doing jokes about chairs and trees and stuff like that.
So those are safe topics usually.
And this is more about,
even though they'll be like,
you fucker that was a racist chair to why that just no way.
I knew how it was about a cherry,
I don't know,
whatever.
Um,
my mother was a chair,
you piece of Shit,
some blood.
But now,
yeah.
So this is more about grief and loss and,
and you know,
it's a personal thing.
Yeah.
How long did it take you to write the script?
All the way through?
I don't know.
I was trying to do the mass.
Someone else asks me and I was like,
okay,
I think I started writing it about five years ago and then I stopped and I went
to some other idea that I thought would be,
again,
it was a higher concept thing and that's what it was around then that I realized
I'm not going to get money for this.
So I went back to this,
this one,
um,
I shot it in 2014 so it is about three years old,
just from the filming to now release.
I sold the movie a year ago at the Tribeca film festival,
not the one that just happened,
but a year back.
And now finally it'll be out.
So some time has passed in there.
It hasn't changed in the last year.
It's just been sitting there waiting to show it to people.
But the writing took,
I don't know if it took on and off about a year,
nine months or I dunno.
Something like that.
And what do you think you've learned about yourself in the process of making
this film?
Well,
a few things.
Standup doesn't teach you how to work with others.
It really teaches you vigilance and self-reliance.
Um,
fear just,
you know,
you're in a live show situation,
any sudden movement,
it's a very primordial experience.
You're like,
that's a threat like this,
this guy's coming up.
No,
he has to pay.
Okay,
cool.
He's fine.
So you're,
it's a very self contained,
often solitary experience traveling on basically like a traveling salesman.
I just go to a city and do the show,
get back in the rental car,
return it the next morning at the airport,
go to the next city,
etc. Making a movie taught me a lot about how I work with others.
And um,
I found some great collaborators,
which is wonderful.
My DP was great,
my art director and loved the cast.
I,
you know,
I got to cast the movie so I got time to really pick people and I thought a lot
about what my day to day life would be like making the movie,
not just the end product that I wanted,
but process.
I'm sure many of you have encountered this and your work.
Just how important processes.
I just want to like what I'm doing and not chase achievements so much,
but ideally have them be maybe the byproduct of a process that I enjoy.
Um,
so I dunno what I learned specifically about myself there other than I,
I learned that how much I do like working with other people and having
colleagues,
which I don't usually have as a comedian.
I like the freedom of being a comedian,
but as I'm getting a little older,
it's nice eating lunch with other people and having you know,
conversations during the day rather than just walking around a city like a
drifter and listening to my iPod or whatever.
The other thing I learned was I got to see my nose from every angle and we it,
this was a difficult experience.
I mean I know what I look like,
but man,
it's nice to write and direct and star in your own thing.
But man,
you get what you asked for it.
Cause I'm sitting there in the edit for months just like,
well yeah,
okay,
let's use that.
That's the best take over.
I'll get over it,
I'll get over myself.
The world knows what I look like.
I just wasn't quite aware of.
But now
it's tough doing stand up and prepping for that.
Is your writing routine or method just walking around and just waiting for ideas
to come?
Yeah,
I did most of my standup in New York when I started.
I started in New York and I lived there for 14 years.
So most of my writing process was walking around the city,
hopping on the train,
going into a coffee shop,
always with a notebook,
drawing,
writing,
daydreaming.
I learned along the way to be less critical of my self as I was generating
material and I've developed a tolerance for how shitty a lot of this stuff I
come up with is.
Whereas I think early on I was discouraged because I would write a joke and be
like,
that's stupid.
It's not original,
it's whatever.
And then over time I was like,
you know what?
I think it's important to write those down.
Don't worry about it.
Just generate the content and hopefully in quantity I might find quality and I
have found that for me mostly to be the case,
I have to sift through a lot of stuff,
but when I go to make a project,
I looked through my notebooks.
I have a lot of,
I'm not from over the years and I can just look through and find,
you know,
I wrote that as a joke idea.
It didn't work as a standup joke,
but that's actually might be a piece of dialogue for a character to say.
And this single panel drawing could actually be a character for an animated film
idea.
Or here's short story I hadn't thought of,
but this one joke suggests to me,
you know,
I,
you look at your old stuff and I don't remember something that I wrote in a
notebook on a random day in 2005.
So I get to rediscover some of the old ideas.
Um,
so that's always been a part of the process for me.
I moved to California,
I live in a canyon,
we don't have sidewalks but want to go for a walk and we get hit by a car
probably.
So that's not going to help my process.
So I gotta figure out a way to walk.
Cause I think kinesthetically for me it actually helps me to generate ideas
sitting in one place and just a white room would probably not help me so much.
That to me leads to analysis.
Self analysis dovetails nicely into some self hatred and then you have a month
off to the races.
There,
so I don't,
I don't do that.
Um,
so I've got a treadmill desk and I have a treadmill desk and like a little shed
in my backyard and I just get on there when I'm home in the morning and I will,
I,
it's like I have weird vitamins I have to take,
like I have to write a page of jokes.
If I want to do a new stand up special,
which I'm going to do,
I have to write.
So just open up a word document and just put the date.
And when I,
and I just write jokes until I get to the bottom and then I kind of put that in
a folder and work on whatever script I'm trying to write or a comedy essay or
whatever,
do my email and all that stuff.
And it's,
it turned out to be a wonderful metaphor for Hollywood because I'm just going
nowhere.
I'm just walking
literally on a treadmill just trying to write my movies that nobody's asking for
it.
That's good.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
Nice.
Going back to early days.
So I,
in my thorough research for this talk,
um,
you were in law school.
Yeah.
And then full rides for law school and then on the second out of three years,
yeah.
You were like no Mohs,
correct.
Comedy time.
Yes.
I went right to law school out of college and I had a scholarship,
which was nice.
So I didn't have to accrue debt.
Um,
can I accrue,
is that,
am I using that word or does it accrue itself?
Whatever.
Wow.
I didn't have debt.
That's how
my vocabulary is shrinking as I get further into comedy.
So,
um,
I thought I would be a public interest lawyer.
And then shortly after getting into law school,
I just realized that I don't care enough about other people.
I'm just a snapchat might be true,
but,
but it's more that I just wasn't suited for law and I'm not that thorough
person.
And I think I found when I was in law school would seem to require a lot of
thoroughness.
Hmm.
Um,
I,
I write short jokes and I don't think that's by mistake.
once I get a punchline or too off the topic,
I'm kind of spent,
you know,
so I moved to the next one.
So to do legal research and all that,
let alone have somebody's financial future or freedom in my hands,
it was like I'm not suited for that.
So like I'm the class clown growing up or was comedy the natural choice?
No,
I wasn't the class clown,
but I've got a friend,
I think I got last with my friends.
My Dad was a really funny person so it was around someone who was funny.
But then in law school I became kind of the class clown and that was a bad sign
because
how are you doing?
So,
um,
okay.
Just doing crowd work for the people.
The other campuses.
A couple of people entered the room.
Yes.
But then in law school I think I was trying to be funny cause I was,
it was like a mismatch and I was just trying to break out of it or something.
And what was your first sound upset?
Like my first set I did,
uh,
I think about six minutes and I did 12 jokes.
Could bless you.
Somebody sneezed that was not,
could Jesus,
it's not like a religious moment.
Bless you for asking that question about my past.
Yeah,
I did 12 jokes and about six of them worked.
It was thrilled.
Yeah,
I was,
I was totally psyched.
And then,
then I did,
actually,
I had booked it so that I did stand up on a Monday night at this open mic was my
first thing in a comedy club.
And the second night was the very next night Tuesday in a bar called the Ye olde
triple in,
in Manhattan.
It was on 55th street.
It was a small comedy show there.
So I did the second night right after.
So I figured when a bomb the first night I'll pick myself back up and I'll try
again the next night so I can just kind of get this over with and feel what it's
like to bomb.
The first night went really well.
So now I was excited because it was a great eye.
I,
this material works and I had more confidence and I was doing the same
materials,
so I thought,
so be good.
And then I went the second night and just died.
I mean,
nothing.
I got no last with the same set.
It just bombed.
It was really tough.
I remember the first night I got into bed after my said I got home and I
couldn't sleep.
I was so excited.
I was like,
I'm a comedian.
I'm like,
you know,
I'm going to be a comedian.
This is going to happen.
And then the next night I couldn't sleep,
but for a different reason.
I just like devastated.
I was like,
I don't understand.
Like I thought those jokes were funny,
you know?
I learned quickly just how unpredictable it is and every audience is different.
Yeah.
It's setting time.
You're following somebody dirty.
There was something happened.
Someone's in a bad mood.
There just aren't that many good laughers I like,
Oh,
I love comedy,
but I'm not a good laugh for,
I realize it now are bad audience from you.
It would be just a bunch of people like me.
We're having a good time and they like it,
but they just smile cause he's a comedian.
You're like,
I'm dying.
You know,
that's how I am.
I just spoke and I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that's a good idea.
Like that asshole.
Like give me something smiling,
laughing.
So you learn a lot after,
you know,
I'm 20 years into it,
so I've been in front of lots of different crowds now.
So it's good exposures.
It's helpful.
But is that the advice you would give yourself if you can?
If I could go back.
Yeah.
I would um,
write things down and record yourself if you want to get better,
record yourself and listen to and,
or watch yourself as painful as it is because I think you can get better,
faster.
I think it's,
there's something very unhealthy about it.
Um,
I'm selling myself.
I try not to do material about myself because I just don't think people want to
hear it.
And I,
you know,
it's just too self involved.
So that's why I think I liked doing jokes about objects and,
you know,
observational stuff.
But I'm trying to learn how to share more personal stuff at the same like I love
Richard Pryor.
I mean Richard Pryor talks about himself,
you know,
I'm all ears.
It's just you've got gotta be interesting enough I guess.
What do you love most about doing standup?
I think creatively,
it's really challenging and I so far have not gotten bored of it and there's so
much freedom.
I think these days,
some of that freedom is qualified because you have to be careful about what you
say.
I'm not particularly edgy,
but um,
as Comedians,
you know,
we use audiences,
they help us.
The audience guides you and they teach you if you're on the right track or not.
They guide you so you need an audience.
And sometimes you might see something inappropriate or over the line,
but you just,
it's like you're drawing or sketching with people there.
It's like they're kind of the notebook in a sense.
But that's still as difficult as that is these days in our internet culture.
I still think there's so much creative freedom there and stand up.
It's really cool and it's,
you know,
it's a great job to have.
Um,
so yeah,
I still love it and you know,
I want to do stand up for as long as I can.
Yeah.
When you were for me,
I think if you really believe in yourself and believe you can achieve something,
oftentimes you can.
And when you were first starting and you're like,
what was your inner dialogue where like I can do this,
I'm going to,
I'm going to make it.
When I was first starting as Dorky as it might sound,
so I was,
I was broke.
So luckily I didn't have law school debt but I had zero so I wasn't negative
anything,
but I was pretty much at zero for money.
So I got temp jobs and um,
I trained to be a proofreader.
I did that for awhile and like law firms and financial printers,
I would just proofread documents,
you know,
paid a decent hourly rate and I would write jokes.
Proofreading worked out nicely for me because I didn't have to answer phones or
interact with people.
I just had to correct documents and I had a notebook next to me and I could
write down joke ideas and it's still kind of daydream while I was doing was kind
of mindless.
Um,
I think,
shit,
I've forgotten the question.
So was it,
what was it,
what'd you say again?
What was the question was,
what did I tell myself?
Because I was like,
wait the time travel thing.
But I already answered that in my time traveling in my own head.
Now what I was going to say was doing those jobs,
I got a library card in New York Public Library card and I just,
I had this commute.
I was living in the Bronx at the time and I was temping often downtown in
Manhattan.
So I was riding the train for sometimes three hours a day,
depending on what time I went home.
It was just a long,
the train went local for half the ride because it was way up there.
But the library card saved me.
I couldn't afford to buy a lot of books,
but I could take him out of the library.
So,
and this is 97.
I was reading like four books a week cause I was just reading for hours everyday
on the train and comedy books or just know I was reading Abraham Maslow,
I remember it was a big book for me is that the further reaches of human growth
I think it's or human experience can't remember but was just about the pyramid
of needs like self actualization theory and stuff.
I read um,
the transcendentalist I went back and read,
I remember liking that stuff in school.
It was like in some ways some of the first self help books.
And then I did read self help books too.
Mostly nonfiction.
I wasn't really reading literature novels or anything.
I think it was trying to pump myself up and I made a little notebook and I would
photocopy pages that had things that I liked,
passages that I like and I take the photocopies and cut them out and paste them
into this little notebook that I would carry.
And they were really inspiring quotes and that helped me a lot.
It's really a dorky answer but it's the truth.
And this made me feel like I was on some sort of quest and that,
you know,
I did have a dream and I was going to pursue it.
But you share that with other standup comedians with,
what's that notebook?
I don't think so.
I'm trying to,
yeah,
I think there were a couple of people probably I talked about it with you.
I became closer with but I remember one time I was at um,
Caroline's comedy club in Manhattan near Times Square.
This is a couple of years into it.
So I was getting spots and decent clubs and I was backstage,
I had a long board at the time and used to skateboard everywhere around
Manhattan.
It was a big skater when I was in middle school and high school.
Yeah,
I had the half pipe in my backyard that I built with my friends.
I love skateboarding and I was okay.
I thought I was good at it but it didn't pan out for me.
That's not my calling.
But,
um,
but I skated a lot.
So when I got to New York I got a,
I got a long board cause it's more stable.
It's like easier as a kind of commuter board and I couldn't afford cabs so you
can take the subway north and south but it's hard to go across town.
So when I went from spot to spot I would skateboard anywhere.
So anyway,
I skated,
I had the skateboard that night.
I'm backstage at Caroline's and some older comics came in and it might've been
like Mark Marin and Jim Norton.
I think Jim Norton was one of them.
You guys might not know these,
you probably know Marin.
You might know Jim too.
Jim is actually quite successful.
But in the comedy world these guys are very successful.
At the time they weren't like big successes but they were ahead of me and they
were like my elders in a sense.
And there's like a real kind of tough guy vibe in New York at that time.
Tough crowd with Colin Quinn was based on some of that scene that was at the
comedy cellar.
And I call it like tough guy comedy.
Suddenly I'm backstage and these guys come backstage and another comic and I had
a book with me,
which was
something like how to read poetry and fall in love with it.
I taken out of the library,
so I'm back there reading this book and I've got my skateboard and I just got
crucified by these guys.
You know?
It was just so I was like not inclined to share a lot of my,
my personal sensitive,
my,
yeah,
my personal educational pursuits with people,
but for me comedy felt like art.
I read a fair number of books about painting because I remember thinking,
you know,
are comedians are kind of like artists.
Each has his or her own style.
You can be part of a community but you don't usually paint with another person.
You don't do the painting together.
It's happened,
but most people just paint alone.
That's what skateboarding was like.
I skated with my friends.
You develop your tricks,
he's developing his tricks,
you skate together,
but we don't do the trick together.
I'm on my own course and I'm developing my own repertoire.
And that's how standup feels.
So you're together and you share this experience,
but,
but it's ultimately your own,
so it's private.
So that's why the reading was helpful to me.
Yeah.
And within the comedy cellar,
would the other comedians,
um,
where they be like,
would they give you advice?
Are the ones that you respected,
would you seek advice from them?
Yeah,
sometimes.
Um,
anything that stuck with you,
Liz Winstead I was an intern at the daily show.
Um,
when Craig Kilborn was the host.
So this was early on,
around the time I was temping,
I got this job in the audience department of the daily show.
Liz was the head writer and cocreator or the daily show,
the original one,
excuse me.
I asked her for advice once and she said,
you know,
you can't please everybody.
It was simple.
She was like,
you can't,
you'll never make everybody laugh,
so don't worry about that.
Don't try to do that.
Just find your people.
I thought that was really helpful.
Um,
I'm trying to think of other things.
I don't know.
I can't remember specific things,
but I do remember certain people,
like Greg Geraldo was,
was really nice to me.
He had gone to law school also,
and I think he practiced before it became convenient.
So we had that in common,
just the law school experience.
So there were certain comedians who were very,
um,
I don't know if mentoring is the word or like avuncular,
but they were nice.
They were welcoming,
whereas many were just kinda like,
Oh,
who's this asshole with the backpack?
You know,
that's kind of the vibe you get.
Huh.
And then if you could do,
uh,
any,
any career that didn't involve comedy and also money doesn't matter in this
scenario,
what would you want to pursue?
So I can do any career in my,
you're a trillionaire,
so Julian or,
okay.
Shit.
That's definitely fucked up.
My moral fiber.
Now what job do I do that doesn't get a laugh to Google?
MMM,
mmm.
I really like drawing and painting and I'm not very good at it,
but I really enjoy it.
So I think I'd be a trillionaire painter who base gigantic works and he just has
his own warehouse that doesn't,
I wouldn't have to worry about selling them at that level.
Our materials would be quite expensive for the kind of stuff I'd want to be
doing.
But um,
yeah,
but I'm a Chilean or you know what I mean?
I,
I have my own island and it's,
it's like an art island,
you know?
And when I die,
it's like a weird installation.
They're all paintings with my money,
just stacks of money.
Um,
probably something in the visual arts I like.
Yeah,
I like drawing and painting a lot.
Um,
again,
I'm,
you know,
I'm not self deprecating,
I just,
I,
I've seen the work of great painters and mine is not that work,
but I do like it.
I really enjoy doing it.
So,
so that's kind of a perfect fit if I had a lot of money,
because when I'm painting,
I feel like I have a flow experience.
If you guys are familiar with that term,
the book by Mohali,
anybody knows how to say his last name says that.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um,
I've read that book years ago when I was first starting comedy,
um,
I thought it was a great book and that kind of was a nice companion piece to the
Maslow stuff because it talks about peak experiences and flow experiences and
flow being it just is coming out.
Yeah.
The idea from what I remember was flux readings of certain characteristics.
One of them is you have a discernible goal and you then can achieve it and on
the way to achieving it,
you lose track of time because you're so immersed in what you're doing and
hopefully what you're doing is also using your particular bundle of talents and
abilities well enough that you're fully engaged.
Um,
from what I remember in the book,
he talks about the difference between,
God bless you,
pleasure and enjoyment,
pleasure being like eating some cake or I dunno,
having sex or something like that's,
it just feels great while it's happening.
But you're not,
you haven't necessarily grown or felt,
am I saying that right?
Do you remember?
This is not necessarily a feeling of like growth or development at the end of
it,
whereas enjoyment had in his description,
it did have that feeling.
Mountain climbing was an example.
I remember from the book,
if you interviewed someone who's climbing a mountain,
like as you're hanging on the side of it and their fingers are digging into the
Rock,
you having fun,
I'd be like,
no,
I'm going to fucking die and leave me alone.
I got to do this.
But then when they get to the next level,
there's a feeling of enjoyment.
They're totally engaged.
It was difficult,
but yet there's feeling of enjoyment,
which is different than just like kind of blogging on your couch and eating ice
cream,
farting quietly under a blanket.
You know?
That can be fun,
but that's not necessarily a growth extent.
Quietly,
he says,
yeah,
that's interesting.
Do you feel that that you enter a state of flow when you're on stage?
Occasionally if I'm in the right mood,
not always.
Yeah.
Sometimes it feels like work,
but yeah,
I try to write a lot more onstage now.
I tried to improvise more and be more and that makes it more fun.
Is that ever a part of your no,
I never did improv.
Yeah.
I never did that and I,
they never did sketch comedy or any of that stuff,
so it was just stand up for me.
But now,
yeah,
you know,
some years into it I I feel comfortable enough to improvise and do crowd work
and stuff.
So yeah,
it gives me a better chance at that.
But if I don't do that,
then I kind of just,
it's just more like a presentation now.
It's just like,
here are my jokes.
Right.
Cool.
I've got one more question and then we'll pass the mic around.
So if you guys had anything,
just raise your hand and will chaga tea you.
Um,
so now that you've done dean and it was great and it's a success,
do you want to make more?
Yeah,
it was great.
It's cool cause it hasn't come out yet,
but I'm with you.
I'm like,
I'm going to count it as a success and just like ignore whatever.
How's the movie?
It's a success.
Don't worry about it.
I get it and it's done.
Okay.
It's a movie.
Just watch it and shut up.
I do feel excited that I got to,
you got to
make one.
It was hard,
you know.
But is it another one?
I want to make another one.
Yeah.
I outlined a movie last summer and then I realized that I,
if I,
even if I got the money for it,
I don't think I'm good enough yet to make it,
cause it would take place in like another dimension and all this stuff.
I'm like,
you know what,
it's going to be too hard.
So I put it aside,
but I have the whole thing outlined,
which is nice.
So I know what,
how the story works.
And then I,
I started a different one after that that I thought I could make if this did
well enough that I got a little bit more money.
Um,
so that's what I'm working on right now.
And the other two films,
yes.
But my goal is not to go starring in all my movies,
but right now I'm still trying to figure out how I make movies and tell stories.
And I have to say there is a nice degree of control in that because I get to
write the movie at home when I'm writing it on my computer.
And then as they say,
you write it three times when you write it,
when you shoot it,
when you edit it,
and if you're acting in it,
then you have even more freedom to change.
So when I'm in the scenes I can feel what's happening and I get to rewrite as
I'm doing it.
Um,
and then in the edit it's nice to have the controls,
the director cause I can reshape it and try different things.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I want it for now,
but,
but I'd love to write movies that don't involve me and that I would just get to
direct.
One of my goals is to write a movie for a woman and to learn how to get better
at writing parts for women because I'm not that good at it.
I just started and I'm a guy.
Not that you can't write women if you're a guy,
but I think there's an arrogance and thinking that you can,
I think you have to learn how to do that.
I thought you did a nice job.
Thanks.
I tried.
I mean it's,
it's important to me.
I think I'm getting roles for women in Hollywood,
especially funny women and older women.
I think it's important.
I think,
I don't think people get worse at acting as they get older once they've had some
sort of head accident or something.
But usually they get better.
So there are a lot of great actors who were older who just want some real roles.
And needless to say,
women of all ages,
they just get short changed and they get,
Hey,
you beat the girl and go laughed at his jokes,
you know,
and you'd be the ex girlfriend.
You'd be the one who's cheating.
You know?
It's like,
I dunno,
it just would be more satisfying.
And it's,
it's not even that altruistic.
I think you tell a better story when you give parts to
women and
people of color and everything.
But it's interesting when you're a single,
I'm not saying,
let me,
when you're a straight white male middle class like me,
it's like the easiest,
smoothest road there is in this country.
You know?
I don't have to tell you guys this,
this like,
so I feel like there is a responsibility if you've had that easier ride to
figure out how to make things that include other people and not just be like,
hey me.
Another story about a white guy in his friends.
You know?
That's a cool challenge.
It's a challenge.
I think it is a challenge.
Yeah.
Because I think it's nice to say,
Oh yes,
I want to write parts for it,
but then you have to like learn how to do it.
Yeah,
empathy.
I mean it's all about empathy.
It's about thinking outside of yourself,
which is hard.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now that we're sad,
why don't we,
let's turn it over to the audience.
Go back to work your ass up.
Does anyone have any questions?
Just raise your hand or ask questions.
We come over here guys.
So you're talking about your first two shows and how the audience completely
changed the feeling of those shows.
If you were in San Francisco versus say Dallas versus some small town in
somewhere.
Yeah.
How do you shape your material to play to that audience versus that audience
versus that audience?
Couple of things.
Luckily I've,
I've been around long enough that I get my crowd in each city,
so it does normalize it a little bit so the differences aren't as pronounced so
I don't have to change too much.
But improvising more and paying attention more to what's happening in the room
has helped me because I can kind of play off of what's happening in the room
enough that it shapes the show.
Um,
I don't like getting heckled.
The one I do that becomes part of the show and I tried to pay attention and so
even regional differences aside is the specificity of each evening and the
people in that room shape it,
but not that much because I've written jokes and I do like writing materials.
So I have my material I'm going to share with people.
I do in my,
in my experience,
find differences in different parts of the country for sure.
MMM.
But like I said,
I get kind of my people in each place.
So it's,
it's,
it was surprising to me.
I remember for a while cause I thought it would be a lot different when I
started really touring around.
And then I,
even in other countries it was like I ended up like in the Brooklyn of London at
some point.
I felt it like it to me at least without insulting London as if they don't,
they didn't predate Brooklyn,
but my experience was Brooklyn.
So I'm like,
oh,
this feels a little bit like Brooklyn.
People look the same.
If I didn't hear anybody talk,
I could kind of swap people and be like,
you walked down union and park slope.
Like you look like that and you,
you're going to go over Williamsburg and to Brixton over here.
Yeah.
How's it going?
Hey.
Um,
so obviously stand up falls in the category of public speaking.
so I was wondering what type of advice would you give someone who might not
necessarily be interested in stand up but is interested in like public speaking
and different avenues?
Um,
in terms of like dealing with nerves,
because obviously like we've all heard the age old trick of picturing everyone
in your underwear,
but who wants to actually do that?
So like what other types of advice have you either heard or found useful for
yourself?
Um,
that you can maybe pass on to us?
Yeah,
this is for me an interesting question.
Let me think about this.
So like I said,
my,
I think I said my dad was a priest.
So when I was growing up,
I got to see my dad give a sermon every Sunday and he just had like an envelope
with just like a word or two on it and then he would just speak
extemporaneously.
So I grew up thinking that's just like something you do.
I saw my dad do it and he kinda did 20 minutes every Sunday and we'd get laughs
and stuff.
And it just seemed natural to me.
So I did pick a good job for me cause I,
I'm fine with public speaking.
I never got nervous doing it.
But I've thought about a lot about it over the years is I read about how it's
like one of the top two fears people have.
It's like death or Publix,
whatever it was.
It was like,
it's up there.
And you know,
I,
I think about it,
I mean personally I'm not sure what the best techniques are,
but I walk the room and see,
she was like,
this guy's not a good public speaker.
I'm out of here.
What's good about this room and the door?
It's like a ref.
It's got a gasket on it or something.
It's like a refrigerator doors.
She's smart.
She's going while I'm talking about us,
I know people at Google are smart,
you know?
Oh,
you're going to get ask a question.
I say even smarter than,
I mean,
yeah.
So,
um,
I have found that failing is one of the best things developmentally of all in my
experience.
Because when I,
before I started,
I was afraid of bombing and I did Bob and I still do occasionally and I
certainly bombed plenty,
but then you bomb and nobody cares.
It's,
it's amazing how much,
how little people care about you
or me.
Do you know what I mean?
It's just incredible to me.
I saw a friend,
ones have a bad set on Letterman and I felt for him and I thought,
oh my God,
like it didn't go well and I realized nobody cares.
Like it's like he,
maybe he cares.
I'm sure he cares.
His girlfriend,
if you have one at the time,
maybe his mom,
if she watched,
I don't know.
Like you're literally talking single digit numbers,
people who care and now I've come to a point where there's so much content that
for any of it to be remembered for even,
I don't know,
10 years,
maybe 50 years,
it has to be extremely,
exceptionally great or exceptionally horrendous.
Like I feel like you're at those little ends of the bell curve.
Everything else is in the middle and completely vanishes.
I'm under no illusions that what I'm saying right now.
It doesn't fucking matter.
This is gone.
So it's like,
I dunno if that would take the pressure off,
but I do.
I don't think that's hyperbole.
I think that's just the truth.
So I dunno,
when you shrink that down out to public speaking in some room,
it's just like,
all right,
I hope people are entertained while it's happening.
You know,
you do your best,
but just seems like it just vanishes.
God,
I'm feeling really dark.
So what was the talk like?
I think he was a comedian.
He seems sad to me.
Didn't he make a movie?
You should be happy with something about the universe is pointless.
And I guess there's No God if he just listened to his talk is certainly no god
present
entries.
Well,
it's not quite polished.
That other thing you did.
I loved their shelf,
your book and I hope I liked the movie too.
We don't know yet.
He said success.
Um,
I wonder where,
where do you get the most inspiration from?
Is that fund,
the treadmill Palm,
like on the low reading a shamble labels,
like in the Museum of Modern Art.
Yeah.
Um,
I went to the,
I went to the Matisse Diebenkorn thing at,
at Moma SF Moma.
I don't know if it's,
you guys call it Mama Marissa.
That was great.
So I do,
I love going to museums and when I go on the road,
I often,
the first thing I look for us to see what museum is in that city and what's
going on there.
And that's nice.
I find museums are great places to wander and daydream with my notebook and
stuff.
Um,
I've learned over the years for me,
I try to find inspiration wherever I can and I really try to play games.
Um,
nothing creepy.
It sounds creepy saying that,
but I'm saying like constraints,
I dunno.
Like for example,
you know,
I like palindromes I think because there's such a challenging constraint when
you try to develop a palindrome the rule that it has to be the same forward and
backwards by letter,
you know,
that kind of palindrome and that hopefully it makes sense.
Those two simple rules yields so many difficulties.
Um,
but I think it can also yield surprising results.
And you know,
years ago I had made myself learn how to write and draw with my left hand.
I don't do it very well,
but even that maybe is pointless.
But the mindfulness that it kind of invokes just by doing something difficult
made me feel more perceptive or present in what I was doing and those kinds of
games,
wherever I go,
I can kind of take them with me so that I can find inspiration in different
places.
But sometimes,
like I've done things where I just like bring a dictionary on the plane and just
read the dictionary.
It's seems kind of boring or stupid,
but I,
I still like paper books,
so that helps me a lot too.
Just to have a thing I can flip through,
but I'll just read it and see if ideas come out of it.
They usually don't,
but I might learn a couple words,
but sometimes something,
or when I first started doing stand up,
if I was in,
it's like some shitty open Mike,
you're waiting to go on.
There's like nine people in the audience.
It's not going to go well.
They're tired.
You're in the basement of a bar.
It's like the lower east side at the time.
I would do this one room a lot.
And before I go on I'd be standing next to another comic and I say,
Hey,
can you give me a word?
And they would say,
I'm saying,
just tell me a word.
I'd be like toaster or something.
And then I would just add it to my set list.
And then when I was on stage,
I would make myself do a joke about toasters even though I didn't have one
because the stakes were so low.
I'm bombing anyway.
What does it fucking matter if I tell a terrible joke about toasters?
You know what I mean?
So,
um,
yeah.
So I would do things like that and I figured,
hey,
maybe if I do it a hundred times,
maybe two times,
I get good jokes out of that and someone's helped me write a joke.
Helped me think of a premise I didn't think of as long as I can tolerate the
other 98 shitty ones that I wrote.
It's like,
to me it's,
it's the kind of game oriented.
And,
and again,
anything that drives me back into the process and not so much towards results
seems to stimulate my creativity a little bit more.
For me personally,
thanks so much for being here.
The last incident was actually really interesting for me because in school I was
the girl who is known for reading the dictionary and being really into
palindromes and trying to write with my left hand.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
So that was interesting.
But that's not what my question is about.
Um,
so in between painting a painting or writing a standup set or I'm creating a
movie,
how do those different mediums express different messages that you want to tell
her?
A story that you want to tell?
Yeah,
I think this is an interesting question for me too because I think a lot about
this and trying to,
let's say,
um,
rotate the crops or whatever,
like trying to basically just keep my career going.
You know what?
If I can get work doing standup,
that's great,
but you can't go to every market every year,
so you've got to stop.
So then maybe I can do something else.
Maybe the movie works.
If it doesn't,
okay,
maybe I can get an acting part.
If that doesn't work,
then maybe I can write a book.
And if they don't want my book,
okay,
back to stand up,
but enough time has passed.
I failed for a year,
let's try something else.
So it's made me think a lot about how the,
the medium can inform the content.
And I think a lot of my favorite things and whatever medium they're presented
through,
um,
probably use that medium pretty well.
So that I've seen plays that have worked really nicely as movies,
but it sure would have been great to see it as a play because it was written for
the constraints of the stage and that kind of blocking and being in one place
and in one time.
Whereas a movie that might involve,
involve time travel or lasers and stuff might not work as well on the stage.
Right?
Because you're not getting to take advantage of,
of all those tools at your disposal.
And I've found that to be the case with standup,
which is presentational.
You can tell stories and do characters on stage,
but it's still kind of a one person presentation.
Whereas with a movie,
I get to act with other actors and I,
I have music that can come in and I can be tight,
I can be wide,
I can direct your attention.
So in each attempt at generating content for me,
I really tried to think about the medium and how I can maximize what I'm doing
in that medium.
So for example,
in my movie I play an illustrator.
Um,
I want it to be an illustrator in the movie because I had a giant rectangle that
I could tell a story on and I could show my drawings in ways that I wouldn't
otherwise get to do it.
I show drawings on stage sometimes,
like on an Easel and I've done a book of drawings and that's cool.
But to get to put them next to some,
uh,
an image of someone else doing something,
now I have a different game I can play here visually,
if that makes sense.
So yeah,
I think a lot about that.
Or do you generate content and like different kind of ways and stuff?
Yeah.
So maybe you find the same thing where,
um,
I w I sometimes want to force something into one form,
but it doesn't work.
It's just,
it kind of speaks back and says,
Nah,
this isn't going to work as a drawing,
so forget it dude.
I'm like,
okay.
But once I learned to respect it,
the process more,
I feel like answers started to reveal themselves.
They don't always work,
but you know.
Yeah.
Thanks.
I can't believe that you do palindromes and all that stuff.
It's a,
yeah.
Yeah.
I might Google though,
right?
Like,
do you guys,
are you have a reputation we holds can kind of say,
yeah,
let me stereotype you all.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
thanks for coming today.
Uh,
I really liked what you said about you making an effort to write more women
characters.
Uh,
I think that's awesome.
My question is,
are there any recent films that you really like or movies that are coming out
that you're excited about?
Yes.
Um,
I really love Brooklyn.
I don't know if you guys saw that movie.
It's a couple of years old,
but I saw a little bit later,
but my wife and I saw that and that one really stayed with me.
I've been on a Hitchcock kick lately,
so these aren't recent movies,
but I had never seen dial him for murder and that was actually a play that was
adapted into a film.
I really liked that movie.
I like to catch a thief,
which I hadn't seen before,
so I'm trying to educate myself going through different directors work now.
I watch city lights for the first time,
which is a Charlie Chaplin film,
and I thought that was great.
So my answer's going to be probably not as current as I'd like it to be.
I don't know.
I,
I really liked superhero movies.
I wish there were a couple of coming out,
but I feel like there aren't any superhero movies or anything like that kind of
stuff out there these days.
But if they ever make those remakes and superhero movies are probably my
favorites.
Just when I hate her original ideas that are smaller and like personal,
I don't know what's coming out that I'm excited to see.
I'm a little behind on stuff.
Um,
I'm trying to think of what else I love.
You can count on me that that's not so recent either.
But to Kenny Lonergan film,
I want to see Manchester by the sea.
I heard it's really sad.
So I'm trying to figure out when's a good time to do that.
Probably if I'm sad about something else,
if I'm like,
all right,
I'm already bombing.
Like let me just piggyback that rather than ruining a good mood.
So I'm
working through some stuff here that you guys don't need to hear about it.
Yeah.
All right.
I just have a quick question about like doing exactly you love for
work and at what point you decided that because part of the attraction of going
to law school is almost that you don't need to do what you really like for money
and then compromise the quality of that or money.
And do you ever feel that a,
you have to tailor what you're saying to make more money and it's not really
what you want to do or be that it affects what you find funny in the real world
and whether or not you're able to appreciate comedy
naturally?
Yeah.
I haven't found a to be the case and be to some degree.
Um,
I feel like part of my brain broke a while ago because I've been exposed to too
much comedy and I've been trying to come up with funny things for too long,
so it's just like blown out some sort of wiring in my head.
So now for something to really make me laugh,
someone probably has to get really hurt,
falling off.
It's just terrible.
It's just kind of what happened,
you know?
Um,
but I have,
I've thought about this a lot because I,
I feel lucky that I got to take something I love doing.
I found a thing I love doing.
So that's a lucky thing.
And then I got to get money for it.
So it became a job.
But the problem is it did become a job.
So it did adulterated a little bit,
but now my fantasy is that I somehow gets successful enough that it can become a
hobby so that you can almost go full circle.
So that again,
if I were trip the trillionaire painting as a hobby because I'm not going to get
money from painting,
so that one's kind of pure because of the limits of what I can do with it or I
don't have the energy to pursue it,
whatever.
But comedy,
I've made a job and I'm certainly not the most successful at it,
but I can make a living doing it,
but I do have to think about it as something I'm selling.
Yeah,
it'd be cool to be super successful and then to just do standup for fun in
direct markets to go to cities that I like.
I love going to San Francisco.
I love going to Portland.
Chicago is really fun.
I love going back to New York.
You know,
I have my spots where I like to go and however much you guys travel,
you have your list.
Yeah,
it'd be cool to go to those cities,
do a couple of shows for fun,
go to the museum,
go to a couple of restaurants or whatever.
But I still feel like,
yeah,
I have to,
I'm going to shoot a new special in December and I have to work on those jokes
and pump them out and of kind of worry about it where I didn't before,
before I did comedy,
I didn't wear it.
I just would maybe be funny at this party or not or whatever.
But now it's like I do a show,
people show up,
they got a babysitter,
they're sitting there and I'm like,
shit,
I didn't do this isn't good enough for them.
Fuck they paid to see me.
You know?
So yeah,
it's,
it's like there's a responsibility and then I'm making every answer sad at the
end.
I don't know why.
No,
I think it's because that's how life is.
Okay.
We got one more.
It's,
I'm a little more,
no pressure.
Good.
Um,
what was it like being on set,
like of a movie?
And then also how did you get to know like the actors do you are working with,
but then also get to know them as characters?
And did he find
that confusing knowing people personally,
but then if they were different in character?
Yeah.
Being on the set was,
it was a mix of excitement,
gratefulness,
a dread,
and then fear became more of it because it was such a low budget movie.
I had all these illusions about what I would be doing and how my movie was going
to go.
And then we'd get there and they'd be like,
Oh yeah,
we don't have a location.
Like we're not allowed inside.
What I thought we were going to,
no,
yeah,
we can't go in there.
I'm like,
the actors are getting makeup right now.
What are we going to do?
I don't know.
Shit.
So that was like really hard.
The practical parts of it were so hard and they kind of just compounded,
it got so difficult.
And then of course the fear kind of multiplied because I wrote it,
directed,
it started,
hey,
hooray for me now I'm in trouble.
It's all my fault.
I have nobody to blame.
I'm like,
this is going to suck.
I don't want this to be out there.
So that that took the fun out of it pretty quickly.
But once I kind of settled down,
it was fun to work with.
The other actors I knew Rory Scovel,
he's in my movie,
he's a comedian so I knew him beforehand,
but he auditioned for me,
which was nice.
So I could see how the lines worked and if it would be believable as the
characters I conceived him and then all the other parts of people audition
except for a few offer only parts.
Like Kevin Kline did not have to audition for me and I was grateful that I even
read the script and when he read it and agree to do it,
like made the movie happen and everything.
So I was getting to know all of these people as we were shooting.
It was really cool.
It was,
it was just a privilege because you get to make the thing together,
you get to do the scene together,
you find it together,
you know,
you're listening to each other.
And I told everybody,
Hey,
I'm not precious about these words.
I wrote the script.
If we can do better,
let's,
you know,
if you can top it,
go for it.
If you have,
you want to improvise,
I'm totally up for that.
So I think that created a pretty good environment,
a good,
a good working environment because,
um,
I wanted to let people do what they were really good at.
And that included my director of photography and my art director wardrobe.
It's,
it's really cool to get to work on a movie because it really is so
collaborative,
like down to every detail.
And it's nice to be the director because you can guide how the process goes.
And so,
you know what I want,
this is what I had in mind.
But I think one of the great things about it is that you have other people to
help you make decisions and you can find the solutions together.
And when it works,
it's just gratifying in a different way than when something you just did
yourself works.
And then now that I'm at this stage,
you guys haven't seen the movie.
I hope you do.
I'm glad you liked the movie.
The people I've talked to who liked it.
It's different because as Comedians we need validation for whatever happened in
my life.
I didn't get beaten up by my parents or anything like that,
but something happened to me.
I Dunno what that I need people to like me more than the normal person.
So it's kind of a curse,
you know,
to have to go out in front of crowds.
I mean I liked joking around and the puzzles of it,
but I think I want,
you know,
validation we all do to some degree.
So to make a movie,
it's just,
especially one like this,
it's very personal and I am just kind of opening up a lot for better or worse
when it does connect with another person,
it's validating in such a specific way that honestly makes me feel a little less
alienated.
Then I sometimes do because of the way the world is going these days and
politics and online hatred,
you know,
all that.
I don't have to tell you guys what we're living in right now.
So,
um,
this has been a surprising,
I don't know what you'd call it,
gift or little oasis,
just for a short little window here where I get to do screenings and people come
up to me afterwards and say,
you know,
I lost someone and this is really meant something to me,
or I liked how you did that,
or,
you know,
thanks for doing something like this.
Whatever it is,
it just feels like,
wow,
I don't know this person.
And suddenly I'm having a very real conversation with them when most of the time
I'm not talking to strangers,
you're just not allowed.
You can't just go off and be like,
hey,
how's it going?
Especially as a guy,
you can't walk up to people start talking and be like,
what the fuck away from you now?
What do you want?
You know?
So it's,
um,
it's nicer to have that kind of interaction with people.
And even this,
I know we're,
I don't know what this room is considered a conference room or sure.
Some sort of,
I know you're controlling the world somehow
in this room.
I don't know what it is,
but you get to come here
and,
um,
you know,
talked to a bunch of people.
I don't know,
you took the time to ask me about my life and everything.
You know,
it is validating in a,
in a different way that's,
um,
it's easy to not take,
it's easy to take that for granted,
but to say,
hey,
you know,
what's a nice moment where people gave me some attention and I got to share what
I think and feel.
And about 90% of the people stayed in the room.
That's pretty good.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I thought this was great.
A lot of fun.
I know everyone else had a lot of fun.
Um,
and let's just think,
Dimitri Martin for coming to [inaudible].